an international police operation has
shut down what's believed to be one of
the world's largest online markets
dealing in stolen identities Europe's
policing agency europol says more than a
hundred people were arrested in the
operation which spanned 17 countries
Genesis Market offered more than 2
million identities for sale with prices
ranging from 70 U.S cents to hundreds of
dollars depending on the nature of the
stolen data
the data offered on the so-called
Genesis Market made its way to The
Operators of the platform through
criminal acts such as ransomware attacks
and malware on the platform cyber
criminals use the data to commit acts of
fraud they attempted to commit a crime
with falsified data to hide their
identity the investigation is far from
Overton is a cyber security analyst and
he's joining us from Leicester in the UK
very good to have you with us on Al
Jazeera first of all do we have any idea
how the website and the people behind it
was able to get hold of the information
in the first place
and yes they they installed they
installed the malware on lots of
computers around the world using the
normal normal channels that malware
spreads through so people people
clicking on links that they shouldn't
have it and and things things like that
the normal normal channels and this this
malware uh still stole credentials and
other information about people's
computers uh in a way that made it
exploitable and it actually remained
resident in in those computers also to
operate them and gain any new
information I want to come back to that
in a second but what could people do
with this information if they bought it
from the website
well the the most sophisticated thing
that they can do is they can they can
pretend that they're these people uh in
the olden days we
cyber criminals would just steal
passwords but passwords by themselves
are in many circumstances aren't enough
anymore because there's all sorts of
other detection going on to see whether
somebody is using a different computer
coming from a different place things
like that and in order to to the next
stage in the arms race if you like is to
not just steal the password but also to
steal the information about the computer
that the person is operating from so
also to to pretend that you're on that
computer and they actually built a
Chrome extension that allows people to
to pretend that they're operating from
the web browser of the the people that
they stole the data from uh in order to
not set off alarms uh by coming from a
different place having different funds
installed and all those sorts of things
that can be used to be important
specific computer that does bring me on
to what I wanted to ask you about this
given the fact that they were able to
place some sort of access and get some
sort of access in the first place how
deep into the systems was it possible to
go
they have malware installed for for the
serious time so quite deep my My worry
is this this will be uh deeply installed
in all sorts of individual people's
computers but some of these individual
people may have been people working in
Industry uh people people who who have
accessed work email from from uh from
home particularly when we were all
improvising uh um computer access to to
critical systems during lockdown we had
to do something suddenly and uh people
will not have have used as stringent
security as as we would now expect from
bring your own device and uh foreign
foreign device policies in in companies
so I think I think there's there's uh
the potential for for serious cyber
attacks uh through through
um
beyond the individual computers in this
story as well one of the things that did
surprise me was that we're used to
hearing similar types of stories like
with companies websites that are found
on the dark web this one was accessible
through what I would call the regular
web the the the normal web is that
surprising that does that tell us about
the confidence that the company perhaps
felt that it was able to be accessible
in the open as there were
well there's there's not that much not
much that much fundamental difference in
there we also know that a lot of a lot
of bad stuff on the internet happens in
closed Facebook groups for example so
the the mechanism that guards all that
is is some sort of invitation mechanism
you need to know that it's there you
need you need to be let in and
essentially the dark web uh functions
functions much in the same way uh
everybody can get into the dark web but
you can't you can't find you can't find
things unless you know where where to
look for them and if that's if that's
what we're looking for well then it
might as well be on the on the open web
to some extent although uh the fact that
that the whole operation has now been
successfully uh stopped may may indicate
that that this this model was slightly
weaker than the dark web model
potentially we need to hear that we need
to hear the detail of how they managed
to stop it and and I expect it to some
extent we won't get that detail ever
because it's sensitive and useful from
future cases given given the fact that
they're obviously the the police have
obviously uh very pleased with the fact
that they have been able to deal with
this particular website I'm gonna guess
that that doesn't mean that this puts an
end to the problem how widespread do you
think this is and how difficult a job is
it going to be for the police to deal
with this and if you can just do it very
briefly that would be great
uh these these particular website wasn't
well known since 2018 2019 to be
operating the investigation has lasted
that long uh I I've got some slight
hopes still that this was this was an
exceptionally sophisticated site and
that there aren't that many direct
competitors to it about but we need to
wait and see the model the model is
available people know how to operate it
so it may or it may well arise again we
appreciate you being with us and Al
Jazeera so thank you very much indeed
for your time
thank you